en las calles de kabul el control total
está en manos del talibán
sin embargo 125 kilómetros al noreste
estas tropas se están entrenando para
resistir los
esta es la provincia de panchir un valle
escabroso y de difícil acceso es el
último gran bastión del refugio anti
talibán en afganistán
el domingo representantes del talibán
dijeron que habían enviado a cientos de
combatientes para tomar el control de
panshir ahmad masood líder de la
resistencia afirma que sus fuerzas están
listas para enfrentarlos
la gente del valle de ban gira está muy
unida y quiere defender luchar y
resistir contra cualquier régimen
totalitario en total serían wiggins
contra cualquier creencia que quiera
imponer su propia creencia ideología
sobre la gente de pib massú es hijo de
maciá masud reconocido comandante
guerrillero que fue asesinado por al
qaeda en 2001 bajo su liderazgo el valle
de panshir resistió con éxito tanto la
invasión soviética de 1980 como la
anterior toma de poder de los talibanes
en los 90
unasur pide al tal iván que negocien que
formen un gobierno inclusivo y de base
amplia
en panshir se le ha unido andrew lazar
ley hasta hace poco era el primer
vicepresidente de afganistán y quien
insiste en ser el líder legítimo del
país después de que el presidente afgano
huyera ante el avance del talibán en
kabul se estima que la resistencia de
panshir asciende a miles de combatientes
sin embargo sin el apoyo internacional
son pocos los que creen que podrían
resistir una ofensiva talibán a gran
escala durante más de unos meses